the crisis over the latest reported
chemical weapons attacked by Syria's
government against its own people is
escalating amid growing international
outrage and threats of retaliation
russia's military claims Israeli fighter
jets attacked a Syrian government
airbase overnight the UN Security
Council plans an emergency meeting this
afternoon the bombing that used a
possible chlorine agent happened over
the weekend in the town of Duma outside
of Damascus more than 40 people
including women and children are
reported dead on Twitter President Trump
called out Russian President Vladimir
Putin and Iran for backing Syria's
ruling regime and warned they would pay
in his words a big price Holly Williams
is following this unfolding story from
Istanbul Turkey Holly good morning good
morning this alleged chemical
bombardment comes as the Syrian regime
attacks Eastern guter the last
stronghold of Syrian rebels close to the
country's capital Damascus and we should
warn you that the video is emerging from
the town of Duma in eastern goota where
this alleged chemical attack took place
involved children and are very graphic
the video show lifeless bodies with no
visible injuries all of them seem to be
inside buildings survivors struggling to
breathe many of them children and being
washed down apparently to remove a
substance from their skin
we cannot independently verify any of
these videos and we don't know whether a
chemical weapon was used
survivors though reportedly smelled of
chlorine a chemical that can be deadly
in confined spaces we received many
patients who suffer suffered from
symptoms compatible with exposure to
chlorine gas high concentration chlorine
gas chlorine is thought to have been
widely used as a weapon in Syria's
7-year long civil war but as the Syrian
regime assaults Eastern guter it's once
again denied using chemical weapons an
attack in guter in 2013 killed hundreds
with a much more deadly substance sarin
nerve agent under international pressure
the zoo
in regime agreed to hand over its
chemical weapons stockpile but the deal
didn't include chlorine another sarin
attack almost exactly a year ago killed
scores of people in the town of Honshu
hoon in northern Syria blamed by the US
and UN investigators on this Syrian
regime the u.s. responded with missile
strikes on a regime air base nearly 60
Tomahawk cruise missiles targeting
aircraft and ammo dumps if this was in
fact a chlorine attack and if
investigations find that the Syrian
regime was responsible the question is
whether this will draw an international
response
John Holly Williams force in Istanbul
Thank You Holly